pft on yahoo sports peter king mike
florea of some of the big stories in the
national football league and one of the
big stories of the 2020 season peter
the fall of the new england patriots and
they've got a trip to buffalo coming up
this weekend what a loss
to buffalo
that would drop the patriots to two and
five signify the end
of their reign
atop the afc east and really atop the
nfl for the past 20 years
i mean do you need a loss to buffalo to
show you that i mean even if somehow
some way look part of the thing about
buffalo right now is josh allen
you know looks like 180 degrees
different in
between the second month of the season
and the first month but
but we digress here
in my opinion i don't think you need a
loss to buffalo to show you that
do you really think that the patriots
can rebound this year to win a division
with one of the worst five six seven
offenses in football
and a defense that
can rise to the occasion occasionally
but is not a great defense either i
you know the the time for the patriots i
think is over mike and
they have to concentrate i believe on a
deep
rebuild and that's going to start
figuring out whether cam newton is the
guy and it's going to continue with in
my opinion bill belichick finally coming
to the realization
that the quarterback and the offensive
coordinator
simply cannot be
asked to be the solution for all of the
offensive problems there is not a single
skill player on that offense that any
defensive coordinator in the league says
man we got to be worried about x on
sunday
and i wonder why that is i mean they try
to draft guys for those positions they
never go out and sign an expensive free
agent i feel like this is part of that
broader system that that is premised on
not paying guys very much money and
skill position players who are good and
who get to the market they get paid a
lot of money and belichick is trying to
ensure that he's got that middle class
of backups who can step in he's got a
bunch of different guys he can use
whenever
and it works until it doesn't and now
it's not i'll say this though
i'm not ready to throw in the towel on
the patriots and i think if they do beat
the bills this weekend now they're gonna
have to win some more games they're
gonna have to do some more work they've
got a hole to dig out of but it won't be
quite as deep if they could beat the
bills sims has been saying all week on
pft live that the bills don't match up
well with the patriots patriots can stop
the or the bills can't stop the run and
the bills can't run the ball and that
plays into what the patriots can still
do well and and i think if they could
just settle down i think that whole cova
thing when cam newton tested positive it
just knocked everything out of whack for
the patriots and they've been struggling
to get it back and maybe this is the
week they get it back now if they don't
two and five losing the bills maybe they
are done
but i still hold out hope that that
they're gonna find a way to get better
as the season progresses make chicken
salad out of a bad situation and if i'm
any of the contenders in the afcp to the
high end contenders the chiefs the
titans the steelers the ravens i don't
want the patriots rolling into town in
the divisional round no way no how
because they would be very dangerous if
they got to the to the playoffs
remember the seinfeld episode where
george costanza at the party
finds the clown
okay the clown comes in to entertain at
the party the clown has never heard of
bozo
and george is railing on this clown and
the clown says you're living in the past
man you're living in the past you're
hung up on some old clown
mike
you are living in the past
i don't know how the new england
patriots of the last couple of weeks
can go in anywhere right now anywhere
and and win now look
if cam newton
all of a sudden you know shakes off
whatever slump he's in
and he's pretty good and he can run and
he can complete a few passes but it's
mainly based on his legs and cam newton
taking over games like he used to the
way lebron does then i'll change my mind
but
man i just don't see it i don't know
it's like watching the rams this week
you know the rams and the bears you keep
saying how in the world do the bears
have five wins with that offense i just
i cannot picture
the patriots rebounding even though they
got two games against the toledo mudhens
aka the new york jets i don't see them
coming back mike
bottom line i like clowns named bozo you
like clowns named eric we'll see you
next time for more pft on yahoo
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports